[Music]
hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
GameSpot here at e3 2014 and I'm sitting
with some very special guests here at
the turtlebeach booth and since you guys
are more well-known maybe for what you
sound like even than what you look like
why don't you introduce introduce
yourselves and give a little tidbit of
what people at home might know you for
can you start with you Shh
sure I'm John DiMaggio and you might
know me as a frisky robot that likes
booze bender I'm Nolan North and you
could free yeah I do a lot of games
Nathan Drake the penguin dr. Richtofen
etc etc let's go to thank you for let's
get it out of all pull out Who am I I'm
Troy Baker I play Joel in the Last of Us
I was Booker DeWitt in BioShock Infinite
I got to follow them this guy's
footsteps and be Joker in Arkham origins
and yeah you guys just finished a panel
here at Turtle Beach about bringing
sound to life is that right apparently
apparently that's a great term we should
have used that where were you when we
needed you we basically were paraded out
there like they're just circus monkeys
they gave us microphones I don't
remember what I said and a lot of
bananas I mean I walked in here and you
guys were already spitting voices back
and forth so I would say you don't need
too much guidance we don't we just don't
stop it's just a constant bumping into
walls and making voices as we do it
understand that that literally what we
get paid to do on a day-to-day basis
some people more days than others but
what we do is exactly what we do in the
you know in our normal life I mean
seriously I mean but we have more fun
between takes than we do actually
working so you know cuz you know he'll
be doing voices I don't think oh I got
to steal that for my next job and then
he'll do something and I'll go I got to
steal that I still more his though
speaking of your job for people at home
who might not be too familiar with what
what a voice actor actually does to make
a voice for for film for television for
games what is it like to sit down and
create a character in a voice for a
video game and what's that that process
from from you to the gamer well I mean
it's different it's different than
animation I can tell you that much
because in animation you have a script
that you stick to it's either 11 minutes
or 22 minutes depending on the the
length of the project if it's a film and
you know have a lot more dialogue but
with a game the performance is you have
to go through the whole game and and and
and and and there's so much that you do
as far as as far as gameplay is
concerned you know all the all the umph
Sandoz and and everything and that I
mean that's that's pages and pages of
stuff that we have to go through so it's
a little different than doing animation
but it's just as fun and and and it's
just as thrilling I mean I I grew up
playing video games so to be able to be
in one it's kind of cool to play Gears
of War a lot when I was single and
living in an apartment in Hollywood and
all my neighbors thought I was crazy
because I was talking to myself too much
and they didn't realize that I was
actually coming out of the speaker and
and yelling at the game it was it was
kind of it's still crazy I still have to
take the meds but I don't anymore so you
kind of we're talking to yourself like
you could yell at yourself I'm not
taking the meds anymore taking your meds
but no but it's it's I mean it's a lot
of fun to get to to get to crafted
characters is a joy and and at yeah we
have we all have a blast and that that's
that's a lot of fun just where my mind
went
it's like guys we've lost John he's last
seen running naked through Hall the West
Hall you know speaking of running
through the halls you guys have quite
devout followings in video games I mean
all day as I've let people know I was
going to get to talk to you they were so
excited too
hear about that to see this interview
what does it like to be at e3 and to
kind of have that recognition and you
know walk around do you get recognized
do you sign things do people ask you to
say things all the time and that's
that's pretty cool because I mean we're
this is a level playing field of nerdom
you know and that's that's one thing I
love and even a moment like the other
developers it's it's there's kind of
this sense of competition kind of dies
down a little bit because everyone is
just excited to see what everyone's been
working on for so long and so we're just
here be-bopping around I got excited to
see call of duty I went to the Mortal
Kombat 10 demo and was just laughs a
it's I don't know how they haven't
managed to keep that or how they've done
it to kids it to keep it fresh you think
out of 20 years it'd be old but it's not
it's just so good so yeah and so when
someone stops and goes hey I know who
you are because there's something cool
that you did that means a lot to me
that's that's pretty that's pretty rad
you know so I'm always grateful when
people say I always think that that's
that's our version of applause really
because we don't get to hear we don't
get to hear what people think of it and
then when we come to like a convention
like this or to a Comic Con or to you
know conventions across the country you
know or you know yeah it's anywhere it's
it's always nice to have you know to
have people come up to you and say say
how much they appreciate your work you
know it's just um sometimes you know
there there isn't enough hand sanitizer
to go around so I'm kidding kids I'm
kidding hang your towels to dry a lot of
times it ends with a Silkwood shower
well you know speaking about your craft
and these these deep meaningful things
that we're talking about you know what
when someone comes to you and says you
know this character of yours really
meant something to me it's part of my
story it's you know something that I
will take with me into the rest of my
life how does that feel and you know
does that you know I would tell you I
did an appearance one time in London in
a 40-something year old constable from
another town actually came three hours
the
tell me how much he enjoyed the
Uncharted experience because he said you
know my life is I wake up I remember
never gay so I wake up I take my tea I
go to work I come home I play uncharted
go to bed same thing and you know he was
here somebody who's you know a law
enforcement in the UK and he had you
know he said I he told me he said I'll
never get a chance to go to these places
to do these things to be this hero he
said but I get to feel like that and I
wanted to come down here just to say
hello to you and just thank you and I've
never forgotten that because you know
let's face it I mean I played games when
I was a kid and you meet some of the
younger kids and guy boys and girls and
they come out and and and you know but
the gamers become more savvy they've
gotten older and more sophisticated and
then to meet somebody like that who
clearly wasn't much of a gamer but he
loved that particular game and it struck
him in a certain way and I'll never
forget that I mean it was one of it was
you know I mean I joke around a lot but
that was one of the people that you know
made me whenever I get kind of
frustrated or something with something
in this business which I never should
because we're pretty lucky to be doing
this you know I think of something I was
think of him because what we do does
affect people and it you know that you
know it's it's uh I know some people who
are you know big fans of the games that
they've been in I've been in and you
know maybe they're you know they can't
do anything else I mean I've met some
kids in cerebral palsy that are big-time
gamers you know and their life is in
that chair and you know there's you know
these games take them to a place that
you know nobody can can go to except you
know a true hardcore gamer so it's it
means a lot
there's definitely meaning to be found
in videogames for sure there's a lot of
heart in it a lot of heart well so quick
well in terms of what's up next for all
of you guys what exciting projects can
we look forward to from each of you what
what can I say
there's a there's a fun crossover
sentence Futurama episode coming up in
October which is pretty really it's
pretty awesome it's pretty really
awesome gosh what else is uh there's
there's adventure time is still going
strong gosh what else there's all sorts
of stuff but what there's a thing that
the three of us are doing that are we
allowed to we allowed to talk about just
say that we're doing it because I the
last I heard there's a big performance
capture game that we performed in
together that was really a lot of fun I
hit him in the genitals during filming
it was very funny
yeah right on the flap they got more the
twig less of the berries yeah but um but
the yeah but the three of us are in a
really really big game and we were
really excited about it and yeah so
that's good and that's coming up there's
a game called this is a game called the
shadow of Mordor that may or may not
have all three of us you made it could
be okay anything else coming up from you
no I'm not and you try what's exciting
from you I'm excited about uncharted 4
coming out because they just showed the
trailer at the Sony press conference and
it looks amazing and I'm a huge fan of
the Uncharted series I hate this guy but
I love Nate right we've got a Call of
Duty advanced warfare is you know again
that's actually coming this year but
unlike some other games I'm super so I'm
excited about that shadow of Mordor
which is coming this year Lego Batman 3
and there's some other good things that
are on the on the horizon Oh far cry 4
cool thing the DVD with all the extras
and all the fun stuff for I know that
voice the the the documentary I did
about voiceover actors that's yeah you
were in that I was in that June 17th
check the website check amazon.com it's
it's a doozy it's really really really
good and it's got a like it's got so
much stuff in it that we weren't able to
fit in the Moon
and so that's really cool so check that
out awesome guys I'm getting the I have
to wrap it up signal from my producer
but I could talk to you guys all day I
really appreciate your time thank you so
much let me know what exciting things
you think are coming up for these guys
what you're really looking forward to
from them by tweeting at Anna Prosser
with the hashtag GameSpot III
[Music]